LISA WRAY: Hi, my
name is Lisa Wray
and I'm a Developer
Advocate at Google.
Today I'm going to talk
about MediaRouteProvider.
In the last episode, we talked
about the Android Support
Library MediaRouter.
That was the first part of
our series on the Media Router
Framework, the API
for any Android app
to cast its content via
supported media routes
to remote devices.
In this episode I'm going
to cover MediaRouteProvider.
A MediaRouteProvider can be
used by other applications
to control media content
playback equipment such as TVs,
stereos, and home
theater components.
If you are device manufacturer
then this DevByte is for you.
Makers of media devices
can publish their products
as media routes on Android by
implementing their own MRPs.
The providers can then be
plugged into the framework
and presented to any
Android application that
supports media routes.
This approach
allows applications
to control content
playback equipment
without knowing the specific and
possibly proprietary interfaces
to manufacturers'
playback equipment.
A sample implementation
of MediaRouteProvider
is the Google Cast
SDK, which allows
apps to cast content to Google
Cast-compatible receiver
devices, such as Chromecast.
If you've use one, you
know how satisfying
it is to cast a video
from your mobile device
to the big screen.
First, an important note,
the media route framework
we're examining here is the one
in the Support Library, which
means it is backward compatible
with Android 2.1 and above.
It supersedes the media
router classes in the Android
framework, meaning
should not use them.
Use the classes in the v7
Media Router Library, instead.
So how do we get started?
Subclass MediaRouteProvider
and the constructor
we register one or
more media routes
was using a media
route descriptor.
Each route needs
control intent filters.
These filters tell
applications that
use your route what types
of features are supported,
including playback controls
that play, pause, rewind, fast
forward, et cetera;
queuing features
or playlist management; and
session features, meaning
Android device to playback
device connection management.
You can also set many other
capabilities of the route,
such as the playback
type, which can
be remote playback
or secondary output.
The media type can
be audio or video.
The volume can be
fixed or variable.
And intent filters
we just discussed
define playback controls such
as basic controls, queuing,
and session management.
Next, you need to implement
a route controller class that
extends MediaRouteProvider,
RouteController.
This class handles the
actual media control requests
from other applications
supported by your route.
Anything you defined
in your intent
filters including playback
controls, queueing,
and session features.
This RouteController
class acts as the wrapper
for the proprietary interface to
your media playback equipment.
This is where the magic happens.
Your implementation will depend
on your specific media device.
And finally, it
should be instantiated
in this helpful named method
onCreateRouteController
of your MediaRouteProvider.
Next is the service wrapper.
To enable other applications
to use the provider,
a MediaRouteProvider should
be wrapped in a service.
To do this, extend the
MediaRouteProvider service
class and provide an instance
of your MediaRouteProvider
from within the class.
You can make a
media route provider
private within the scope of
an app by simply calling media
route [? add ?] provider,
no service needed.
But in this example, we'll
make the MediaRouteProvider
available to all
apps on the device.
To do this, our
application must declare
in the manifest a
service declaration
for the MediaRouteProvider with
an intent filter for Android
media MediaRouteProvider
service.
This service is the same
one we just looked at.
Finally, the
provider should watch
for changes to the
discovery requests
by implementing
onDiscoveryRequestChanged.
In this method, we kick off
an update of the media routes
the provider describes by
finding the routes that satisfy
the new criteria specified
by the current request.
To publish them we create a new
MediaRouteProvider descriptor
with information about each
route and call setDescriptor
again.
This notifies the currently
registered callback.
And this process usually
happens asynchronously.
If you are a manufacturer
of media playback devices
or you work with one, the
MediaRouteProvider is for you.
Android devices everywhere can
be casting to your MRP shortly.
Please take a look at
the docs and sample code
and get started.
My name is Lisa Wray.
Thanks for watching.